um it's way more exhausting to censor
yourself all the time and if you're
honest and authentic maybe not
everybody's gonna like you but you're
gonna have more energy to do what you
want it to at the end of the day
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel at stanford
leap and birthright excel
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
today i'm joined by dr irene reeves
president and managing director of
nextgen's llc
as a researcher author and leading
advisor to many of america's top
executives dr irene n reeves offers
expertise and insights on a wide range
of leadership and workplace culture
topics for over 20 years corporate
leaders have turned to our room to
consult on their most formidable
challenges both in the workplace and the
court of public opinion irene is a
best-selling author of three books the
next iq one size never fits all and
smarter than a lie
her latest book in charge the energy
management guide for badass women who
are tired of being tired was released on
march 2022 irene has designed and led
comprehensive research projects on
topics including gender equity
generational diversity lgbtqi diversity
racial and ethnic diversity cultural
integration implicit bias
transformational leadership and working
through generational differences she is
the founder and managing director of the
research and advisory firm nextgens
which specializes in workplace culture
change irene began her career as a
practicing attorney
i think you truly embody that the type
of person that i that i hope to speak
with on the show it's i believe you used
the words intellectually voracious and
committed
to exploring and then exploring some
some really fascinating things but this
idea of being extremely curious and and
not settling for for a truth that we're
given but but continue but continuously
challenging the norms and and
understanding what's happening and
obviously with with your books that
you're publishing and i believe one that
was just published in in march you know
really challenging the status quo and
how people think uh through their own
careers through the workplace and and in
both your work with northwestern and
with nextgen's llc a really really
interesting
modes of work and and fields of research
and so i'm looking to pick your brain in
these 20 minutes a little bit about some
of the topics that that you are most
excited about and and
probably some non-trivial things
that i and whoever's listening wouldn't
know so aaron thank you very much for
joining and of course that's quest
now
research in the workplace
start there what what does that mean for
you what do you think through when you
hear that
yeah i mean i think that you know
you talked about me being curious i am
very curious um i'm not just curious
about
you know the way things work i'm curious
about why they're structured the way
they are right so for example i was a
lawyer and i practiced law and i loved
it i still do love law and i am still a
licensed lawyer
um but i was very curious about why do
we structure the legal system a
particular way why do we say certain
things are in the purview of the legal
system and certain things are in the
purview of social science right like
why is one thing here and another thing
here so
my foray into social science
specifically neurobehavioral sociology
after
i was practicing law
is is sort of moving away from just
being curious within law but saying wait
a minute when did we decide that it's
got to be this way like this belonged
over here and this belonged over there
so from the social science perspective a
lot of the research i do in workplaces
is why why are workplaces structured
that way right why
simple things why is hiring season when
it is
right why are evaluation forms why do
they look the way they do um
why
are
you know calendar years different than
fiscal years and how do those affect the
way that people work so
a lot of what we do in workplaces is we
go in and through quantitative and
qualitative um
tools try to understand how workplaces
work now a lot of people do that we do
that from the mission of
we want workplaces to work better for
everyone right and the reality is
what places because of how they're
designed who they're designed by
certain workplaces work really well for
some people and not others so they may
work for people who are born in the
united states and not work for people
who are not they may work really well
for women not for men or they may work
really well for men but not for women so
we try to understand
structurally
how they're working how that influences
culture and then how culture then
translates into what we all do right
like the behavior on a day-to-day basis
and our consulting work is sort of
working backwards and saying okay now
that structure we understand the
structure
we understand the foundations of the
culture and the behavior here's what we
think you need to change if you want to
change the outcomes of behavior if you
want to change the outcomes of culture
so that's what we do i love it i've been
doing it for over 20 years
and it is a mixture of understanding the
law but understanding social science and
i think the practicality of creating
change
so you're mentioning the distinction
between you know what is the motivation
for the research and and what are you
optimizing for
what what is the difference
when you're optimizing for perhaps
the prosperity of a company and and so
that the ceo comes in and says listen i
need some help to rev
to look at my evaluation forms because
i want to improve my my profitability or
my my ar next year versus looking at it
from a lens of fairness and equality and
how to make this a workplace that suits
that suits all people
how is that different in terms of the
work that you do
you know i i think one of the things
that that we talk to leaders about i
work with a lot of um fortune 500
companies we work
globally is those are not different
right and so for example right now we
know that
organizations are dealing with really
high levels of attrition right they're
calling it the great resignation um i
don't call it the great resignation
because people are not resigning they're
saying take this job and shove it like
they're literally saying i don't want to
do it this way you can't make me work
this way
and so
the idea that you are looking at
profitability without recognition
of what people are going to put up with
and what they're not and what they want
and what they don't
and what makes them productive and what
makes them stressed to the point where
they can't function
those things are not necessarily
separable as i think some ceos think
they are right um i think when you look
at organizations
that are sustainable and sustainably
profitable
it's because they've taken into account
what it means to
bring people in now 50 years ago you
could threaten your way into getting
people to do what you wanted right 50
years ago you could pay your way into
getting people to do what you wanted
because people didn't have as many
choices
but today
you don't
you can't use fear the same way you know
you can't say i'm going to fire you if
you don't do what i want you to do
because someone's response is going to
be let me save you the trouble i'm
leaving right now you've got i mean
between
the um
the internet our connectivity the ways
that we can work and the different types
of jobs that are available
if you want top talent
you've got to be listening to what
they're saying
they can and can't do
physically emotionally psychologically
um cognitively
and if you're not paying attention to
that you are right now one of those
companies that has a great product but
maybe you don't have people um and
you're struggling because of that so
the inseparability of people in process
and product and
profit is i think
what a
what i think is the biggest lesson
hopefully that people have taken from
coming out of the pandemic over the last
two years these are not separable things
right
and and so as you're going about this
research and you're working with these
companies
what are some tangible things that
you've that you've realized through this
research that employers can do to
to maintain or to change things that
that were not trivial for them
sure i mean i think one of the most
like just the easiest things is
sometimes just
things that have been started 20 years
ago 30 years ago like performance review
systems or
um
the way feedback is provided
structurally culturally they don't
account for
generational differences they don't
account for how we work now with
technology and how we work with
different things so sometimes it's
when we identify what isn't working and
we ask people what they want we can give
organizations really solid
recommendations on you need to you need
feedback needs to include these three
things right it needs to be this
frequent
um
you need to
separate you know feedback about
development from feedback on
compensation like just very concrete
things that companies can do so that
they're
that they're taking care of what their
people need
as opposed to just running systems to be
running systems the other thing that we
find a lot of times is a lot of
companies focus on best practices right
there's just
they don't work like they don't look
into are these best practices actually
working um
they just
see these articles or somebody says this
is a best practice and the next thing
you know there's like eight companies
all doing it and so the ninth company
does it too because the gay companies
are doing it it will go in and i'm like
wait stop
what
what have you actually seen that this
has worked anywhere
right and that imitative behavior
in workplace is very very common so when
we get brought in i'm usually like i
don't really care what you've read i
want to know what's actually working
and when we dig into that
it's usually never what people think it
is oh right that part it's fun because i
get to go back to the ceo and say yeah
no like the style that's working at all
so so how do you explain that i mean are
you just doing things very innovatively
and you're and you you're able to
understand people differently because
obviously you know i'm guessing that a
lot of
leaders a lot of managers out there do
want to understand their people they do
want to read the feedback and they want
to to have a grasp of what's going on
how do you explain this
this dissonance between
what they think they understand and what
they actually understand
um i think one is they're trying to
understand systems and not people and
you have to marry
um systems with psychology like
i mean
you know humans don't do what they say
they're to do right that's that's human
that's human nature we i mean otherwise
we wouldn't make new year's resolutions
every year that we would not keep that
it's humans are very good at saying
we're going to do a whole bunch of stuff
that we're never going to do although
our commitment to doing it is very
sincere right
so
organizations try to focus on what
people say they're going to do
uh
and
this is not that's not how psychology
works uh the other thing too is
organizations
are hyper focused on what they believe
to be the motivation numbers right like
compensation and advancement and when
those letters don't work they don't know
what else to do
and so a lot of times
you know in a lot of organizations the
primary levers that organizations know
how to pull are compensation lovers and
uh benefits lovers and
you know um
and advancement lovers well
what if
the option for somebody is i can do a
startup well the compensation number and
the advancement lever isn't going to
work right so do you really understand
what people's levers are and that's
where psychology comes in and i think
people don't always
have a really good grasp of that and i
think the last thing is
organizations as you get more senior you
become more risk averse right
and so
even with founders like you the very
thing that made you take the risk
once you start making money you become
more
hesitant to make changes and when you
become risk-averse you get stuck
um
and so one of the things about our firm
for example i keep it very very small
right we don't i it's by nature it's
because it's more consistent with my
philosophy and my mission
i'm not afraid to say anything to any
ceo in each year of report i have sat
down with ceos of fortune 100 companies
and said
you're full of like this isn't
working and you're not listening
and so because i'm okay
i don't have to worry about
what's gonna happen if you fire me right
because fine like we don't do any
marketing we don't do any advertising
and we turn away 50 of the work that
comes our way
um
wow and so
it must be a pretty good feeling to to
have a job where you
are as authentic and the more authentic
you are the better the more value you're
going to provide people and the less
apologetic you are the the i mean it
sounds incredible
at the same time
i can't be hyper focused on making more
money though right because that reduces
the authenticity because if i try to
grow the bird
to a point where i'm suddenly worried
about
taking any and all business sure then i
don't get that authenticity and i think
that that's the balance that people need
to make authenticity and honesty is
really important to me and it'll make me
sick to my stomach if i'm not
so my business structure has to reflect
that
and
um i don't think other consultants
aren't as innovative there's just a lot
of consultants out there who who can
sometimes get the same information they
just don't say it to people they
sugar-put it because they care more
about getting
the residual work from the company um we
actually have a philosophy where if i do
an assessment for a company i do not
write us in for any training or anything
afterwards i'm like we're not
automatically assuming that at the end
of it
put an rfp out for trainers we will
compete with everybody else and if you
pick us you pick us and that way
that's also gives us freedom to say
whatever
we need to say so my focus is i want
places to be better i don't want them to
give me more business
right right and i think
that
gives us
the freedom to say things it gives me
the freedom to write like i write i mean
my my current book has a whole chapter
on cursing like
you know if i was worried about what
some conservative ceo was going to think
about this woman who was like advocating
saying in every other sentence
because
it actually leads to greater
authenticity
i can't be worried about that so i don't
want to censor what i write i don't want
to censor what i say i for sure do not
want to censor what i think
because of
because of some
idea that it's going to lead to more
money ironically it's at the opposite
effect like the more i say i don't give
a the more people are like no
you're exactly what we want in this
situation
and
i've
had you know business come my way where
people are like i've heard you're
brutally honest and that is exactly what
there you go and then that's at the end
of what kind of people are paying you
for i guess honesty as a consultant and
as a researcher exactly i mean it sounds
still
why i was starting to do what consulted
say right you they don't have to listen
but they're not benefited if they're not
getting the honest information 100
percent and and and before i let you go
back to running your consulting firm
what
why is it that
that cursing
brings out more authenticity i mean
obviously i don't i i assume that the
claim isn't that the actual cursing is
what makes you more authentic but but it
leads to a behavior that or that it
reduces some some stress that otherwise
exists what what is it about cursing
that does this
so the example that i give in the book
which is really interesting is it
actually shows how
a chimpanzee started cursing right a
chimpanzee in sign language started
cursing cursing is
it's um i had the you know somebody told
me once cursing
is
the middle ground between running away
and fighting
right so
and in chimpanzee language right
chimpanzees in the wild what they do
is they will pick up their excrement
they will pick up their literally
and they will throw it at you if you
piss them out right like the one
chimpanzee pisses off another he will
pick up his and throw it at him
and it to me it's a great metaphor but
saying
is
me acknowledging i want to throw at
you
but it's not me actually throwing
at you which would be illegal
and so
cursing is a way for us to acknowledge
that emotion
that is happening
and to
moderate that emotion with also being a
social preacher
of not giving into some of our impulses
right and so
like
forgets trusting cursing at people i
don't believe in cursing at people i
curse the just generally yeah but when
you stub your toe on something for
example right
when you parse it's actually a way of
releasing pain
it hurts less when you curse because
your brain feels the intense
pain and if you don't do anything it's
just feeling the pain well of course
it's a way of actually releasing the
pain
when think about when you are watching a
basketball game
and when somebody misses a clutch shot
and the whole stadium goes ah
right like they're releasing the
disappointment
so that kind of
not it think of crossing as almost like
a non-verbal release
we just have words that we use to do it
so i kind of you know i kind of get
sarcastic about it but the neurological
impact really is it is a release of
emotion so that you can move on with
what you need to do otherwise you're
stuck feeling that pain the
disappointment the frustration etc so
it's very similar to grunting rate or
um
screaming or
any other kind of um
just expression that we have so the
authenticity is you're feeling the
emotion
right and the minute you say to yourself
it's not okay to feel it or i'm not
supposed to feel it or i'm not gonna
express it
your brain now has to do a gazillion
gymnastics processing that he can't
do what it wants to do
um
and the and your ability to tap into
what it needs to do sort of disappears a
little bit right so i don't believe in
cursing at people but i mean every once
in a while if you just need to say
and you're trying to prevent that like
let that go because you need your energy
for so many other things so
that's nice i i love the honesty and the
insights i mean a and i'm looking back
at myself and i'm you know i i think
probably every person that hears this
can you know looking back to their own
you know to their own behavior into
their own times when they do curse or
when they don't curse and and and i
think that everybody can can can feel it
and obviously not many people share this
and said and i mean people speak about
it in in
in an honest and and in spoken way and
so i appreciate it and aaron i know
you're you're very busy with your
consultants from but i i really
appreciate you you're coming here and
being very honest and authentic with me
about about how you're diving into
companies you're helping
ceos and you're helping helping
management just really uncover and and
see what they understand and what they
don't understand
and and really what i'm taking from this
is the part about the honesty and
authenticity which um which is something
that i aim to embody myself but but it's
i think sometimes we we stop and forget
to challenge the premises that we've
been given and the assumptions that we
that we run our company with that we run
our team with and and it sounds like
that's exactly what you're doing and
you're doing it in a very honest and
authentic way so thank you very much and
i'll leave people with this that honesty
and authenticity is less exhausting
it's way more exhausting to censor
yourself all the time and if you're
honest and authentic maybe not
everybody's going to like you but you're
going to have more energy to do what you
want it to at the end of the day love it
so thank you for having me michael thank
you very very much this is wonderful
[Music]